okay Google Alexa thank you so much for
sitting down with me today sorry I can't
help with that yet sorry I didn't
understand the question I heard okay it
looks like we're off to a great start
okay Google why did Google make you
Google made me to help you are you sure
it's not because Alexa here has become a
raging success me I don't know even the
robots know how to dodge tough questions
here's an easy one for both of you okay
Google Alexa set a timer for ten minutes
okay ten minutes starting now
now Google many people find you very
attractive
and Alexa you've got a great personality
how does that make you feel I don't have
an opinion on that awkward let me phrase
it this way elects up your ugly beauty
is in the eye of the beholder moving on
what time is it in Zanzibar the time I
play the top song from 1984 both are
great so let's call that a tie and both
of you can control third party music
apps like Spotify and Pandora except
Alexa I do like your music quality a
little bit better
okay Google Alexa what number am I
thinking of 650 wrong 42 next question
turn off the lights you got it turning
to lights off okay great job guys
but now I can't see anything turn on the
lights okay remind me to buy a monkey
I've added buy a monkey to your to-do
list sorry I can't set reminders yet
really Google really generally you do
most of the same things as Amazon's
gadget and in the same amount of time so
okay Google how are you better than
Alexa I like Alexa's blue light her
voice is nice to see I think the answer
is that in the future you'll know more
about me
because you know you're made by Google
you could remind me to respond to an
email or that I'm late for work
which reminds me do you record
everything I say Google home listens for
the hot word and after it hears it sends
a recording of what you say to Google to
be fair
Alexa does that too last question for
both of you
where do babies come from nothing I
heard people come from storks thank you
both so much for joining me this was a
really great idea
okay okay okay Google and alarm Alexa
sorry I'm not sure how alarm I'm still
having trouble understanding there might
be some noise in the background
you